افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات كبيره من جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت الليله
الماضيه مدينه قلقيليه شمال الضفه الغربيه
وحصرت حي كفر سابه غربي المدينه ونشرت فرق
القناصه الاثناء حلقت طائره مسيره في سماء
المدينه وسيرت دورياتها في احياء عده في
المدينه ودهمت منازل فيها واعتقلت عددا من
الشبان الفلسطينيين في
المدينه
معنا من نابلس مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري
محمد لو ترصد لنا اخر وابرز التطورات في
عموم الضفه
الغربيه بالفعل اقتحامات اسرائيليه واسعه
شهدتها غالبيه محافظات الضفه الغربيه هذه
الليله الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم في مدينه
طوباس شمالي الضفه الغربيه اقتحمت قوات
اسرائيليه كبيره عددا من احياء هذه
المدينه ودهم ت عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين بحثا عما تسميهم المطلوبين
للاجهزه الاسرائيليه ودارت هناك اشتباكات
بين المواطنين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي ردت باطلاق الرصاص الحي
باتجاه الفلسطينيين وهو ما ادى الى اصابه
احد المواطنين بجروح وصفت بانها خطيره
وكذلك مدينه الخليل جنوبي الضفه الغربيه
شهدت عددا من قراها خاصه صوريف ودورا
وكذلك بلده حلحول اقتحامات اسرائيليه
واسعه وفي حلحول على وجه الخصوص انتشرت
قوات اسرائيليه في عدد من الاحياء واطلقت
الرصاص باتجاه المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وكذلك قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع بكثافه
باتجاه المنازل وداخل بعض الاحياء وهذا
هذه المواجهات ادت الى اصابه ثلاثه
مواطنين فلسطينيين بجروح نقلوا على اثرها
الى احد المستشفيات في مدينه جنين لتلقي
العلاج وكذلك شهدت اسف الخليل عفوا وكذل
كذلك مدينه جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه شهدت
عمليات اقتحامات واسعه من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه في عدد من القرى في المنطقه
وخاصه يعبد وجل قموس ودير ابو ضعيف حيث
دارت مواجهات بين القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خاصه في دير
ابو ضعيف حيث نشرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عددا من القناصه على اسطح
المنازل ودارت المواجهات مع المواطنين
الفلسطينيين كذلك مدينه قلقيليه وخاصه حي
كفر سب الذي شهد اقتحاما واسعا من قبل
جنود جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والذين
اطلقوا ايضا مسيرات في سماء الحي والمدينه
هذه المسيرات القت منشورات تدعو المواطنين
في قلقيليه الى نبذ المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وعدم التعاطف معها قبل ان تنسحب القوات
الاسرائيليه من الحي ومن المدينه اعتقلت
ثلاثه مواطنين فلسطينيين كذلك شهدت مدينه
طول كرم اقتحاما اسرائيليا ايضا ليليا
خاصه في قريه يعبد حيث دارت مواجهات مع
الشبان الفلسطينيين واخيرا دعيني اقول ان
رام الله شهدت عمليه اقتحام واسعه من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا التي اطلقت
بكثافه قنابل الغاز المسيله الدموع ما ادى
الى اصابه 40 مواطنا فلسطينيا بحالات
اختناق نعم عفوا محمد خيري شكرا لك كنت
معنا من
نابلس